tina takatori halibut my talking one
cool night o night salami to her
anything not to our hotel what me to put
it all gooey
let's go my work attire good morning
everybody my name is holly Peterman and
from night tahoe night that I get to
heard anything that I helped to cut it
to her in I'm 12 years old
seeing the model sorry to AV school 109
Tamara key situated proximity away from
cowboy lots of our students love have
connections play sport in in from cowboy
45 students versed the model about a
month ago from a school as most of these
schools here participated in the same
activity we put a we put 229th legs on
the model majority of the flakes were
new ideas but we did have some concerns
most of my ideas were in saqqaq we South
inquiries here hang on me a pie what
were their highly liked in yeah just
things we liked to hear it America liked
the idea of Len being made available for
businesses qui food and beverage was the
most important having good quality cocoa
sisters and hope we will bring people to
our tacular to our town fast food
businesses were highly regarded p2p
Casey Starbucks and all the schools like
Casey home businesses that promote choir
would give young people like me
something to do so it will keep us busy
we also our second choice was retail and
services was also very important the kid
45 students that came in we highly
support the recreational ideas sports
Vuitton's sports facilities dog parks
playgrounds BMX tricks horse riding
another recreation more ideas like
you have another letter what were the
problems in what with concerns overall
we didn't have many concerns however
here are some of their concerns
obviously the red zone was at one of our
concerns but it was what it's going to
look like so that was a concern for the
red zone time how long it'll take
so we do want it to look this birth in
it perfect as it can so yeah and one of
the other ones was it apart our cemetery
and where it would be based so that was
another concern with fair it's a folk
art or may have a care we kind of looked
at the box and thought of some call
picture ideas we had a zoo a boathouse
panting on the river or dial Park hockey
turf and we did have a little bit of
imagination and thought submarine
factory and then we thought a bit more
realistically and how to kick your house
being native plants etc [ __ ] Cuffy my
conclusion
tamra key from our could have generally
liked the idea in the plan as we didn't
have many concerns so yeah we like the
complain I think having more business
will be good for the town bring
opportunities people will stay for
longer further employment Accenture I
thought the recreational ideas because
once again it goes children like me
something to do keeps us busy we look
forward to the red zone areas being
developed and some things happening soon
thank you
you